Since 2014, a working group has been developing
proposals for the rehabilitation of the Kaiapoi River.
Today we are opposite the new Coastguard building
just downstream of the Williams Street Bridge.
Now Neville, I must say it looks fabulous
across the river here.
I can see a lot of hard work has gone into
making it look beautiful.
Can you tell me please what's happening with
water quality here?
Yeah, well right up and down the river with
everything we've talked about so far, is all
about trying to just take small steps to enhance
the water quality.
As you know, we've got things flowing into
the water that need to be a lot cleaner than they are.
There's influences from upstream, there's
the push-back from the Waimakariri.
We need to make sure that every step we take
enhances the water quality of this river.
And that's ultimately where we want to go,
we want to make sure that this river is cleaned up.
It is in a shocking state, make no bones about
that, it is absolutely shocking and it needs rehabilitation.
Unfortunately, it's the long-game not the
short-game and we have to carry on just doing
step-by-step to make sure we can try to get
some better water quality in here.
Now I understand there's going to be some
dredging taking place, is it just going to
be here? Or how is that all going to work?
Sure, this is obviously the area that is navigated
by boats in and out of here and where they
will park and where they will leave from or
come to.
So there will be a channel through here, one
of the other sediment traps we talked about
earlier could possibly be the actual wharf
area itself.
So when it comes to re-dredging again, the
wharf area itself will be one of the main
dredging points as opposed to dredging the
whole river.
The river deepness past the Courtenay Stream
which is the confluence downstream from here,
which will also be planted in the manner that
you saw up there on the corner, that will
also play a big part in the navigation through
here.
So it will be dredged down to there, the depth
of the water is probably not too bad from
there on in through to the Waimakariri.
So how can people have their say?
Well, right here they can come in and there
will be an open day at Ruataniwha and people
can have their input that way.
We have the website, we have councillors,
community board members and we really want
people to have their input.
There are six proposals we'd like your feedback
on, attend our open day on the 27th of April
or find out more at waimakariri.govt.nz